Umar Patek was released on parole after
serving just half of his 20-year prison
sentence for his role in the 2002 Bali
bombings Indonesia's worst ever attack
he was convicted in 2012 after almost a
decade On The Run of mixing bombs which
ripped through two nightclubs in one of
bali's busiest tourist areas
202 people were killed and hundreds of
others injured a local Al-Qaeda link
group was blamed
citizens from 22 countries were among
the dead 88 of them were Australian
tourists there the news of Umar patek's
early release has caused outrage that I
care about Australia that I care about
the people that died over here they
don't care about the other 21 countries
that were involved at the time they
don't care they only care about the
people that they try to think in terms
of their own mind is to de-radicalize
which is craziness
Australia hard urged Indonesia's
government not to release Patek but
authorities there say he has been
reformed thanks to a de-radicalization
program in prison that hasn't convinced
Canberra my thoughts today are very much
with the families and communities who
have lost a loved one
um this is a person who was in the
Indonesian justice system my personal
view is his actions are inexcusable and
completely abhorrent
we don't control the Indonesian justice
system and that
that is the way of the world for local
victims too the bomber's early release
brings a sense of unease they're
unconvinced that he's a changed man
as the victims directly impacted we have
our own opinions these people cannot do
good they might have behaved in jail but
after they freed can the authorities
guarantee that they will not reoffend
tourists still flocked the island which
hasn't seen an attack since a monument
to its victims reminds visitors of what
Umar Patek and others did here 20 years
ago Freddie acar Al Jazeera